good morning good afternoon good evening today I'm going to
talk in portuguese about
language learning and above all it's
why certain people have
difficulty learning languages is what I always say if yo
have it is that the most important thing is the one that
eeds to have confidence you need to have  the
will is you have to like the language you
are learning is these things are very
very important is it is not almost 70% by
114 influence is success
the second thing is and and spending a
lot of time with the language
reading speaking is this is very important
the thing is to involve the ability to
be aware of what happens is what I have
talked about is often about these things
is the motivation to learn a language
a new language' new to succeed in the
new one is to succeed but there are many
people who have the will  who have the
motivation not to be able to learn a second
language because I think the most
important thing is the fact that they haven't
done it that they don't have the experience of
changing to become a person who speaks
another language
i speak more or less to others like ru
portuguese is not if a law that speaks
very well but i know that
i will spend enough time with the
portuguese language i
will finish to be able to speak portuguese
i have i am like a loser but  a lot is a
lot of people is that they don't have that
experience the confidence they can
get to
speak another language fluently so
when they study all the frustrations
it's done all the things we're going to
learn let's forget that it's
often in we won't understand many
sometimes in the branches of power it's sex you
know what it's like would like to be arrested because
in our native languages
adults we sp
ak it's perfectly freely we ca
express ourselves but in foreign languages we al
ve difficulties so we learn an
forget we can't say what we
mean it's a lot of things in
steward so that's just the
frustrations of language learning
but if you know if you believe you
will succeed
then all  these frustrations are not
important
doc belief and that one day you will be able to
speak and in that other language besides it is
the email when one is sewn in the language
I always do pleasant pleasant things I
listened to the law about topics that are interesting to me
to  culture there is no other culture the
history of the country
other things like this is generous so to me
the learning process itself is
pleasant
so frustrations are not
important because i know that when
we learn a language
the process is long it is long away from the
long long it takes a long
time for the brain to
learn you your servant learn
but it takes time and i also know i do
n't want to pass the language past in
class um i don't believe a teacher
can explain grammar better than
the book that  I can buy and read
when I want and the things I can't
read again I don't want to depend on the
teacher for grammar explanations
I know that only later  a lot of
experience with the language standing up after
having listened a lot
he is a very beautiful goalkeeper a lot the
grammar explanations is i will start is
and then i will talk to other
students says the best
dodo i don't want to listen to speakers of the
language i prefer  listen and clean 3
listen only with castiel is
interesting for me it's me
for example it's with portuguese
i'm very aware that they speak
portuguese very poorly who dictated portunhol
but i know i have the will to
learn portuguese
here's the two  weeks has been listened to a lot
the portuguese team is better now that is the
dose weeks
and o paí o in having more and he didn't say
much but the best is this and the cation the
possibility of spending a few weeks but
brasil is brazil with time listening and
talking in  miami flight is meanwhile it's
like talking like you talked with a lot of zeros and
continuing to use colors is the language and
little by little I'm going to improve myself I have
that confidence a I believe it's very
many people don't have this co  confidence in
they don't know what it's like to study and they
don't believe they don't believe they will be able
to speak another language fluently
so I say you have to believe you
have to have motivation you have to have
confidence you have to spend time you have to
look for interesting things for you
to  listen to read a have to talk
to heroes em don't worry if you
speak with errors a node because the brain
little by little will correct it doesn't
need delta connections someone
else
if the other person will correct it very well
but that is not necessary  you don't need
this collection because the brain or go
little by little if you are and correct
if you can to renew yourself is a stuntman the
ability to be attentive is the
ability to be attentive
is with a lot of experience as the law but
the hard wing and also with  determination and
when are you going to hear a phrase that
you know for example i know in
portuguese
i have difficulties with an old one other
things in crazy try to pay
attention when i am writing  Using reading
so this is me doing these things
because I have the confidence that I'm going to get it
so I'm the people who don't have the
experience of having learned 2 234 in
but have to keep going
have to follow you will be successful a lot of
pleasure is thank you
is a see you  soon